here is a pretty classic sort of
questions that you might receive
which is underneath this heading of
probability but because
there is in this phrase here
is built into this phrase lots of
different ways to combine these
different things
so that's what makes this counting
arrangements and
combinations and what have you as well
as probability okay now remind me
if you want to find the probability of
an event okay it's a fraction
what are you dividing by what what's on
the top
on top is like the chances of getting
the event okay pause for a second
we want a specific event but the whole
thing
is a chance right so there's something
up here which
constitutes part of the chance but
that's not chances right
what do i have up here that i'm going to
have to divide
through yeah i'll probably say number of
ways
number of ways to get the thing that
you're after that's that's what you are
finishing right so up here is number of
ways for
the event whatever it might be like
having two hearts and three clubs
or four aces or something like that how
many ways in that
can that happen and then what's the
total sample space
which is another way of saying what's
the number of ways you could do anything
right what's the numbers you could do
anything now you can see
we now have all of these see these this
is all this language that we've just
developed for working out what your
numerator
is and what your denominator is okay so
let's think about this we'll start with
the easy part of the question first
sample space that's just no restrictions
no conditions nothing
you've just got how many cards in a pack
you've got 52. maybe we want to write
that
right here 52 cards in a pack
and the other important thing that
you're not going to get told that you is
worth knowing
is a hand whether it's poco or this or
that a hand is
five that's why we call it a head okay
so a hand is five cards
you would hope that the question itself
would actually explain it to you but i'm
telling you right now
they very likely will not tell you how
many cards there are in a pack they'll
just
expect that you know and that there are
four suits and they're not going to
tell you that's the case yeah so i'm
telling you now
okay so now we know how many cards there
are to
choose from how many options there are
and we also know how many we want
out of the options so what's the sample
space
sample space
now i think we all know there's going to
be a 52 and there's gonna be a five
right but then the next question becomes
is it a permutation
or is it a combination does it matter
what order the cards are in when you get
them
and the answer is no because as soon as
they're in your hand you can shuffle
around do whatever you like and it's
still the same
can't right does that make sense so
therefore i should be using
c okay now this is a really
big number yeah event
whatever the event now you have a
calculator there right you've got a
calculator
maybe you want to get it out before you
go ahead and punch this in
right i want you to notice 52c5
before i actually get this thing to do
the work for me i can work out what 52c5
should be right it should be what's on
the numerator it's going to be
hey by the way that's a really big
number okay
divided by okay
yeah have we done it right now
clearly you can do some simplifying here
probably the easiest bit
is to say hey look at all of these terms
the vast majority of them are going to
cancel
with these guys does that make sense so
i'm going to get
these big ones here all the way oops
it's a 49. all the way down until
that's it isn't it yeah it's the last
one and then what have i got on the
bottom
five by four by three by two by one okay
all right this is still a considerable
number what is it
um
okay which is why poker is so
interesting to play because you can keep
on getting lots of different options for
a long time
so yeah that's right so now my next
question is
well if this is the sample space how
many ways are there
to get these two things to happen
okay let's take it one piece at a time
you want to pick two hearts
right now this is exactly the same
question as we had before except it's
just like
a little part of the deck right there
are four suits what are they by the way
hearts clubs
diamond spits okay so you're four to
choose from so in each of the suits if
there's a quarter in each there's
13 right that might be worth johnny now
13
per suit okay
so now what i'm trying to work out is
and by the way i mean i just said this
to the extent of two people in the
morning
now please for pete to take you some
words okay don't don't just write a
whole bunch of like
this be that this see that tell me what
you're doing right so i've taught i've
said this is the sample space
so now i want to get the number of ways
of getting two hearts okay the number of
ways you're getting too high
now how many hearts are there to choose
from how many options are there
there are 13 right
and i want any two of them i don't care
about their order
like that does that make sense so that's
the number of ways of getting two
hearts now i look at this part over here
right the ways of getting
three clubs
how many ways 13
yeah very good okay
so i've got all of these pieces here and
i haven't bothered to work out what
these numbers are
now the big question becomes well how do
i combine them now there's an easy bit
um down here we know the sample space
that 52c5
that's going to be on the bottom okay so
therefore i can say
the probability is going to be and i've
got 52
c 5 on the bottom this huge number okay
now then the question becomes well with
these other two numbers i've got
in what way do i combine them together
to get the numerator
okay so suggestion one is multiplying
them like this
okay now let's just think for a moment
just contemplate
why would this make more sense than
adding because it does well
if it was probably that you will get
both
two hearts and three clubs is obviously
going to be less
than getting two hearts and
three clubs i'm sorry wait say that
again three clubs
okay so if someone said okay what's the
chance that you're gonna get
two hearts and three clubs well that
chance is gonna be
lower than getting two hearts or three
clubs
okay so that's true yeah that's true if
so when you have like
and the chance becomes lower so it's
times
because it no i don't know what i'm
saying okay now you said a lot of right
things
but i think they're still a bit
confusing here with weather that means i
should add a multiplier what do you
reckon what would you like to stream
um you could have two hearts and your
other three cards just doesn't it
doesn't matter what they are
right so then you have a you only have
that combination
like you only need to consider the
combination for the two
hearts and if it's an or you can only
you can get that
or you can just get three clubs and two
of anything else okay
before i get the other sessions because
we still haven't i think there's still
more to say here
let me just i'll come down to you so
don't just make a handset i will come to
you
that was a really important question to
ask and it's worth answering now
what if it were or instead of and by the
way
the end is the crucial word okay so what
this means is
okay my sample space is still going to
be 52
c5 yeah i think we all agree with that
but now you can say well all right first
i've got to get two hearts we know what
that is
and then you have to say well how many
cards do you get to choose from for your
other
three cards if all i care about is two
hearts
and the answer is just whichever is left
over
right all the other cards right which i
can choose from okay
now how many are left i've already taken
13 out right
i've taken two out so how many are left
i had to pick out three more to complete
my hair right that was just for the two
hearts it's just for the two hearts
but then in addition to that i can work
out
the three clubs which is going to work
out and what's the same way 13 see
three and
two to complete my hit does that mean
which bit yeah sure okay so i want to
look at what happens
think about the events and what's taking
place right
you've chosen out of the hearts there
are only 13 hearts to choose from
right you chose two of them done
whatever that number happens to be
okay and then you're like but i've got
i've got three spots that are empty
and i have to fill them how many choices
do i have how many
options do i have that i could use to
fill them and the answer is there is
still 50 cards left in the pack and i
could pick
any of them i could pick more hearts if
i wanted i don't care
um i could pick other suits they're all
part of that 50. does that make sense
and it's the same way how i get the 49
okay now this is getting to your
question right like
which of these think which of these
numbers is bigger
is it is it going to be this one
one
well let me ask you this is it more
likely that you've got to satisfy
two conditions or more likely that you
can satisfy either of them at any given
time
either is a lot easier rather than like
both at exactly the same time
right this is a much smaller number this
number is tiny compared to this guy
right just look at that just look at
this guy for a second this guy is
massive right you could be doing this
all day and you'd have
lots of different combinations okay uh
not just all day
all right so just coming back a little
bit does anyone because i thought there
were a few more hands up
just to justify why this is times
just like what you did for like the
hearts why would you multiply for
getting
hearts like to get two heights you have
to multiply 13
and then 12 right it's like normal
yeah but this is like the same pattern
yeah that's right you multiply not
add like a separate
okay another way to think about this
right is that
you think about each of the cards that
are being dwelt and i can't finish this
because this is going to go
it's going to go really far right but
you need this one and this one
and this one and you keep on going all
the way until i can do
there we go till some fifth card right
and we know you multiply a long branches
when you're getting all of them together
right you only add you only add
if it's yeah it's two it's like these
guys
and then there's these guys as a
different alternative right they can't
happen simultaneously
if you've done those you've got ten
cards in your hand right does that make
sense you chose three and then
chose two and then you chose three then
three and then two that's too many cards
okay so yeah question
i was like for thirteen c two and
thirteen c three that part
like you guys like by choosing one out
you would eliminate one choice
one choice from the tiles and i've
already
13 c3 already takes care of that right
because remember look here it is here's
like like say 10 c3
right i've already taken care of the
fact that there's 10 and then 9 and then
8 and then 7.
it's not 10 and then 10 and then 10 and
then 10.
i'm already this thing's getting smaller
this is already taken care of
whether i'm replacing it or not okay
um everything pretty much is really
replacement when we're dealing with
factorials that's why they get
smaller and smaller and smaller because
you're having less options as you
progress
okay now this is a really big number
does someone want to tell me what it is
there's someone right three on me nine
hundred and it's 143 on one
six six six seven one four six
one six six six
like that okay wonderful